Have the government-mandated Coronavirus lockdowns
saved thousands of lives?
Or were they a terrible mistake?
That was the subject of an online Soho Forum
debate hosted June 1st, 2020.
Defending the claim that the COVID-19 lockdowns
were the right move is Marty Makary, a surgical
oncologist at Johns Hopkins and author of
the 2019 book,
"The Price We Pay, What Broke American Health Care-and How to Fix It."
Arguing the other side was epidimologist Knut
Wittkowski, who's the CEO of ASDERA, the company
discovering novel treatments for complex diseases
from data of genome-wide association studies.
Wikowski also served for 20 years as head
of Department of Biostatistics, Epidemiology,
and Research Design at Rockefeller University
in New York.
The Zoom conference was intermittently marred
by weak internet connection and audio lags,
meaning that there were a few moments where Wittkowski wasn't audible that we had to edit out.
But thankfully the recording is mostly in
tact, so here it is, Marty Makary and Knut Wittkowski
in an online debate moderated by Soho
Forum's director Gene Epstein.
Tonight's resolution reads: the lockdown has saved hundreds of thousands, if not millions of lives,
and spared American hospitals the horror of rationing care.
Speaking for the affirmative, Dr. Marty Makary a surgeon and professor of heath policy at the Johns Hopkins
school of Public Health.
Speaking for the negative, Dr. Knut Wittkowski, former head of biostatistics, epidimeology, and research design
at Rockefeller University in New York.